[Музика]
привіт мої дорогі друзі, це я гра
Олена і я вчитель англійської мови, і
сьогодні у нас урок англійської мови
в 5 класі, як зазвичай, simp розкриває, що роман
так, Олена - акордеон Артур рок і
лід  бавовняний крем більш класний
виснажливий, щоб ви могли прочитати
тему сьогоднішнього уроку, в якому є традиції
та свята в усьому світі, а
насправді ми з вами багато чого дізналися
ми вже говорили про
святкування просто будь-які святкування ми
говорили про святкування в
Україні  у Великобританії ми говорили про
фестивалі та карнавали, а зараз я
збираюся поділитися цікавою
інформацією про деякі цікаві
свята в різних частинах світу
в різних країнах
moysha of TTM is vamadeva hitachi hovel
chili Moberly Prosecco Vanya Bock Ragini
Prosecco Vanya is забруднення  амок рельєфи
дерево сповідує долину Pro carnevale
ich iguana mopar mo pro se que VA the
Cavanaugh's Vitara DG business Justyna
sweet over his nec  k Raina, так що Китай, тепер
ви бачите, як Аллах змушує вас чхнути, вони продовжують
записувати так, так, Боснія
, ми почнемо так, і, як зазвичай,
ми маємо список слів,
і це більше для доопрацювання, тому що
багато з них ви вже вивчили
Jana Papa готовий haruko obokata  палиці
наживо Чилі, що єпископ
Тауранги легенда, звірі видаляють
Торію Мотум, що розбивається з тимуса, лама,
мабуть, ні, тож давайте
подивимось на світ знову святкує
жадібні святкування свята Лаванія свята
Джотто фестиваль звичай або
традиція традиція державне свято
ROM не є  національний символ, а не
журналістика, буде демонструвати пароти глядачі
будуть Adichie традиційні костюми готові
tini костюм феєрверки або багаття
віддавали честь дотримуватися цієї традиції ковзати
через прохідність
щорічних, якщо кожен Лі поставити
прикраси Троянда відвідала ядро, щоб
принести удачу ви можете побачити
картину  торт, ймовірно, це торт на день
народження або будь-який інший торт, тому що
зазвичай перший а  асоціація, яку ми маємо, коли
ми говоримо про урочистості та свята,
це правильні торти чи торт, який ви не
бажаєте, щоб ваша покупка стягувала з вас плату за вашу
компанію vanden eykel a mocha bottom
або
фестивальний торт чи будь-який святковий торт,
тому що зазвичай ми любимо торти, ми їмо
торти, коли ми святкуємо щось, він
повинен mooniz отримує торт торта так
просто замість цього об’єднати, що завжди купувати
президент, якщо Rosicky Slava et Saco
2d Anisha маси, які є
коаліцією Обами Куомо  тож ви бачите, що у мене
є маленький торт на дошці, так, у мене
є кілька шарів торта, тому я
хочу, щоб ви зробили, ви повинні думати, що ви
повинні переглянути те, що ми навчилися, і
ви повинні придумати деякі фрази, які
Ви можете використовувати, коли говорите про
святкування, про фестивалі, про
карнавали,
про будь-які сімейні традиції чи свята
та вечірки.
У мене є мій, тому
ми будемо писати разом, ви
пишете разом зі мною, добре,
що у вас тут, я написав, щоб
влаштувати вечірку або організувати вечірку,
щоб провести вечірку і зібратися разом,
тому зазвичай це перше, що ми  робити,
коли ми хочемо щось відсвяткувати, так,
а якщо говорити про вечірки, то ви знаєте, що
це може бути вечірка, це може бути
сімейна зустріч, це може бути шкільний
випускний вечір, це може бути вечірка Діви, це може
бути вечірка на день народження, це може бути  тематична
вечірка.
sherizaan :
Mohammad cavada, що ми зазвичай робимо
на святі, чому ми влаштовуємо
святкування, чому у нас є вечірки, чому
у нас є особливі випадки, коли ми
просто танцюємо, щоб поговорити, це зазвичай
ми робимо, коли влаштовуємо вечірку та коли збираємося
разом  r з друзями чи родиною, вибачте
лише незнайомців на вулицях, якщо ми
говоримо про фестивалі чи карнавали, величезні
маси, які є Обама, Нагасіма, спа-центр
Рамос, Арізона, націоналізм не вірніше,
ніж банофі стимулює моє збереження – зараз
покажи мені фестиваль спогадів про
карнавал
Winspear i'ma  розкажіть su mo Rose macclare
mo кожний Davao надайте більше діаграм, що
ще ми можемо зробити, якщо ми говоримо про деякі
державні свята, деякі національні свята,
наприклад, ми можемо
ми можемо випустити феєрверк,
що означає випускати феєрверк,
вітати макарони і це  зазвичай
чудове завершення державного
свята, це те, що я люблю найбільше, я
думаю про державні та національні свята,
тому що зазвичай в кінці дня
є гарний феєрверк і
феєрверк випускається або просто листівка
я емоційний  палка клавіша там говорить, що я
тепер ви, Люблін збиваєтеся з шляху Честейн Акоста на
національному хостингу Ковіно, так що підсилило
манію боснійського салюту, але цей
справді блюз здається гарним ха  добре,
чим ще займаються люди, ми також
можемо влаштовувати паради, які можуть бути частиною карнавалу чи фестивалю, або ми можемо брати
участь у карнавалах, фестивалях, свят,
святах та інших речах, тому це був
лише невеликий перегляд того, що ми
навчилися та  це були лише деякі
приклади фраз, які ви
вивчили раніше і які ви повинні використовувати
під час розмови про святкові
свята, особливі випадки та
події, добре, і ми рухаємося далі, чи
знаєте ви, що це за
прапор Японії з нічним я  повинен сказати
Флавія Поні про Мусульманську дію не
Будда не О J Будда мас Варма
який різновид Pro Nepal nutrish хокей
готує його спочатку скасувати що Cavani
їсти церемонію Tredici kihyeon їжу, яку
я зробив, якщо вона Аллах вони вони клацають
абрикос ти перед тим, як ми будемо  якщо є
напади, ми будемо читати атаки разом,
але якщо
для цього я просто хочу, щоб ви перевірили, що
ви знаєте, так і зробили прогнози, тому
якщо ви не знаєте відповіді, ви можете
просто спробувати гу  добре, переконайтеся, що ми
заперечили, що вони поставили це так, пропанолова
бомба, але мати радий, що вони говорили
про багато змін, які,
мабуть, не потрібні для відео, просто напишіть
попередній перегляд минулої ночі,
так що зворушливо, так який вид чаю подають
на японській чайній церемонії
так Кріч я наливаю ще, сер, зараз ви
вказуєте Скітер церемонія потреби чаю
чорний чай зелений чай порошкоподібний зелений чай
хор назальний повітря мені на борту кожного
я дав їй школу його особливе ім'я,
як ви думаєте, японець  слово «кімоно»
означає «аква»
кімоно «Мачіас Луїсвілл» щось носити
традиційний костюм або код впевнений,
який емоційний піджак традиційний
костюм кав'ярня розмова про те, скільки смажених
соєвих бобів люди їдять на
Свято весни призначений надавав послугу
біля фестивалю, але  Представляю вам
тут розгромного Боба Лі або просто
винного Тревора, ви, сестри, що радиккіо
100 ставку за кожен рік вашого життя або
500, тож ви думаєте про  відповіді
ви можете робити прогнози ви можете
записати відповіді, щоб перевірити, що ви
вже знаєте і наскільки ви вмієте
передбачати відповіді, а потім ми
прочитаємо атаки і будемо спілкуватися або Java
це BM nama-hatta той самий
гриб в горошок  це не подвійність EVP, оскільки я був
демо-версією mapache. Я застрелю вас на
ніч мого Джуджу, це текст, о, щоб ви могли
побачити японський прапор, ви можете сказати
зображення для традиційної чайної церемонії,
і ви можете побачити зображення першого
з усіх  Фестиваль соєвих бобів, тож це
справді про церемонію чайної
церемонії в Японії дізнайтеся про японську
країну, відвідавши чайну церемонію
Японська чайна
церемонія традиційна церемонія, яка має
довгу історію в особливий спосіб приготування
зеленого чаю, який називається macho oj на
reddit  Eenadu zodavia китайська церемонія
якщо розподіл не є окремими
балами культура не потрібен не потрібен
літо церемонія пальто
накі будда віддає перевагу Олбані О
Б'ярне п'явка Лен я можу прагнути до матча  це
називається способом чаювання. Це
японська культурна діяльність, що включає
церемоніальне приготування та
презентацію порошкового чаю
матча, це просто вампір, який Емілі каже: «Без
церемоній інтерпретації квартира
Родезія кожна церемонія пізніше
сцена абрикос - Ваня чао
і люди проводять чайну церемонію в
спеціальній чайній кімнаті або спеціальній будівлі, яка
називається ча-ча-джитсу, тож це
спеціальна назва санньяса також вірять, що
Кім не є, можливо, вони бохо Будда
логічний О, криклива Кім, красуня, яку ми тримаємо
Риволі церемонія чат-чату, яку носить більшість людей
кімоно Mahakala dave dehyde
кімоно кімоно є традиційним костюмом
Японії, який досі носять під час
фестивалів і урочистостей, тому
традиція
Брейніака ускользнула від солянки домашнього фестивалю
іфтар - наступна лоза, а світове
кімоно означає щось де  там написано
дитина Naveed ввічливість a Patania Cibola
претензійний thomas la víctima no як
Natalia sure Naboo shamone  брудно, так що
стосується чайної церемонії, по відношенню
до чайної церемонії, яку вони готують, вони готують
особливий зелений чай, який називається ma
Chau, а кімоно означає щось різне,
і у нас було ще одне питання,
чи вона належить як бик або депа таня,
мабуть, з вашої дієти, тому боби  Фестиваль горобини,
що це зв'язок — це назва
японського фестивалю, в якому
відзначають початок весни
, тобто ніч Ашок бхай чакра ти
знаєш культуру
Азіани. Перший Брі Гуд був названий почутеком зі мною
на підлозі, якщо ти фестиваль Поні Такаші
письменниця акіни встановлює бомбу II Японці
думають, що кинути соєві боби
принц удача в цьому році кувіра, коли
ненависть це крокодил
Зої Бібер хлопчик це пренер облогової бомби
Адачі люди також носять красиві
костюми та маски
під час святкування кашрут
масок джихаду в  Sahara nico geometry
the tini question glass with co
фестиваль Vanya Tuhoe ви та люди вірите,
що це соєві боби для кожного
року вашого життя gr  нам удачі,
звичайно, ми, Павіні, допомагаємо ще цілувати олійні
сиськи Кім Кібум широкі кубики дозволять магазину
Вон фартух спить на Адажіо, і в мене є
ще одне повідомлення від іншого друга,
так, список завжди кажу, що показав мені
чотири рази, мій наведення заманить вас у пастку.
том каппа Холостяк
нехтує ім'ям Рахіма, у
нього є Потала ша якась навіть
естетика Оллі
так, тож давайте прочитаємо цю частину я чудово,
дякую,
мені цікаво, на якому фестивалі ви брали
участь, люди були традиційними костюмами,
а вони були  багато кіосків з вуличною їжею,
що ви святкували, зачекайте
секунду, ви зараз в Азербайджані ввечері
Костюм ми підриваємо Лукаса з
COO Ваня знімає нижче він обрігадо
Люсію через Арізону погоду Джонні
так, ти абсолютно правий я в
столиці нещодавно пропонує Джон Баку
вони відсвяткували одне з
найбільших національних свят, немає Брюса, це свято
весни, яке походить із стародавніх
перських часів, що буквально означає новий
день,
він є приватним, навіть у тіні, зловісній
з битком у тому, як Ліга Аллен
нападає на мене, це був Куомо, ох, навчав
цьому, коли  це дуплет Радж Капур в
якійсь духовці не липкий
Джоанна каже, що Кавані ATSA розпочав скажімо, що
фестиваль тому це
безпрограшна огія, ви можете побачити прапор іншої
країни Азербайджан, і у мене є лише кілька
запитань до вас, перш ніж ви почнете
дивитися  відео з лікарнею до
попої servido alle папуга же
yahushua в весняний Abajo завжди необхідний
Таня вам Calibri buddha / eladante
відео буде зондувати у ваших даних
namu vid povedilla добре тому перше
питання про яке святкування було
згадано у відео
як ще називається Mazda  від Jessica
Vanya preocupada чоботи PO Chui Toledo
чи є в азербайджанцях Санта-Клаус
вона подарувала азербайджанському Санта-Клаусу Дід
Мороз чи правда, що  люди повинні
прибирати свої будинки і купувати новий одяг
перед новим роком
не зелені замок простирадла схвалено
наднову
Rokon приємне опитування Чанг в
Мохаве a koopa vato ні в якому разі О JA pre
Bharat через Молочне в нама-хатта
окреме тіло  сказати Nova,
що люди зазвичай готують на
святкування, яке він наказав їсти в Остраві,
чи піжама, як я, хто це роблю зараз
a cheerio Oh je veux pas fini Adagio
vajna sloka - було не так, як кажуть,
їдять, що трохи забезпечення міста
Британія  тож настав час для відео, тепер
треба уважно слухати, а також я
б рекомендував вам робити нотатки, щоб не
пропустити важливу інформацію
привіт Група 5 ваша вчителька пані Олена попросила
мене розповісти вам про свято
про фестиваль, про
який я знаю в  країна, в якій
я зараз живу, і це ґрунтовна
робота, тому сьогодні я розповім вам дещо, що
я вже знаю про їхній
фестиваль нового року, який називається безпідставною, тому
це свято відзначається в перший
день  весна і вона триває 13 днів
для цього часу люди прибирають свої будинки
люди купують новий одяг, щоб люди
готувалися до чогось
під час цього свята у них є щось на
кшталт ми знаємо щось на кшталт Діда Мороза,
але вони називають його місяцем куряча
, це старий чоловік  приїжджає до міста в
перший день весни, приносячи з собою
весну і нервуючи, він пише на своєму
білому коні і дарує подарунки добрим
дітям
щось, як Санта робить це під час цього
свята, коли настає вечір, люди
розпалюють вогнища, і вони, як величезні багаття,
і вони стрибають  над цим маленькі діти
вони загортаються в біле простирадло
, ходять від дверей до дверей, стукають
у нього, просять ласощів і нахиляються
в каструлях і сковорідках, чи це нагадує
трохи привіт, так,
це свято і  Традиція також може брати
коріння з кельтського привіту,
тому під час цього свята це
свято неврозу особистості, тому що, як
Абіджан раніше був у Перській імперії,
так і під час цього Перського  свято люди
їдять перський суп з локшиною з рибою,
овочами та рисом на вечерю, коли
приходить Навруз, усі всі
прибирають, усі носять новий чистий
одяг і йдуть до своїх сімей,
якщо вони живуть в іншому місті чи
містечку, а також старі члени сім'ї та
молодь  члени сім'ї збираються
разом, щоб відсвяткувати новий рік,
ще одна традиція, яка сягає
перських часів, полягає в тому, щоб накривати стіл з
сімома різними предметами, які починаються на
літеру s на перській мові, цей
особливий стіл називається haft seen, і
це сім предметів  що ви можете
знайти на цьому столі,
вони включають позначку пилки, яка в англійській мові є сумахом,
часник морські яблука,
струмінь зизифус, сонячна чаша, гіацинт,
паростки пшениці та захищені монети,
кожен із цих предметів має особливе
символічне значення, і, наприклад,
яблуко є символом  монети краси - це
символ багатства, паростки -
символ відродження, а часник -
здоров'я, сподіваюся, ви дізналися щось нове
сьогодні про нервове свято, яке
відзначають не тільки в цій траві на
бруньках в Ірані,
це також стародавнє стародавнє перське свято
, тому ви, подивившись відео,
дізналися цікаву інформацію
про Сабра Джона, і у нас є деякі
твердження, які ми маємо  щоб вирішити
, правдиві вони чи брехливі,
так, тож давайте зробимо це, я покажу
вам правильні відповіді, але Матата, яку
вона отримала для мого геодезичного дослідження, я сказав, що
молитва Ваня може бути нахилена, покупець
лідер міліції, згадайте фільм, так
що дешево  Pravda chinna Pravda
teshia napoo solid also the first one is
no Bruce це святкування Нового року в
Азербайджані, яке програло на 13 днів і
починається в перший день весни
chitara of the should say festival сказав
супутник загального пальто оживляє
нову особистість  Назва Persia Denver
, це правда, так, вона
відрізняється від України та деяких інших
країн, але це правда, що люди їдять
суп з локшиною з рибою, овочами та
рисом протягом дня  внутрішній
я був нижче Patania Pro традиційний
звичайно якщо мене поважають повідок скажи, що
Ден збирається піти до тебе робити шоу
обов'язково суп тіні на колінах показувати, що ти справді
більше Чармін аудитор Правда правда
людина схожа на Санта, який приносить
подарунки пише  білий дорогий Cheetara
з шоу power soba Yakov nephron OC
padorin qui a
caduceus hosana santa clauss allons-y це
королева, вона гордо срає в його digne
Bellomo alling і, звичайно, це
неправда, у них є людина, яка схожа
на Санту, але він їздить на  білий кінь сьогодні
вранці він прийде вони можуть пікадорувати
один одного це протікає це зарозумілість
підприємці в алеї Падука його член
телятина ми будемо Лому монета йому люди
були новим одягом прибирати свої будинки готувати
смачну їжу та купувати нові речі, які
вона казала  пишаються ними, звичайно, це
правда, люди намагаються купувати все нове,
і вони намагаються прибрати свої будинки, і
вони намагаються виглядати красивими, вони були
красивими новим одягом, тому що
новий рік мовчазний  рівні ніколи не
шиєт Реба купа вато темно-червоний Читра
публічно да-да-да-да-да Джакарта це
пограбування Бхарата будем К і люди
не зібралися разом і вони не
святкують Навруз зі своїми сім'ями
йог-сотхот о лу медсестра, що куди
скажи віята ізраїль щиро наречена
Сара там із відео третє,
звісно, це неправда, тому що за
ість цього вони збираються разом, вони влаштовують сі
ейні вечірки, вони відвідують св
їх родичів, а старші члени сі
'ї збираються разом із наймолодшими чл
нами сім'ї, тому  всі
родини збираються разом
і святкують це чудове свято,
тому урок закінчився, і я сподіваюся,
що ви дізналися багато
цікавого, і я сподіваюся, що вам сподобалися наші
уроки про святкування, тому я бажаю
вам  чудовий відпочинок дня, і
мені було приємно працювати з тобою,
до побачення
[Музика]